[Music]
all right I'm just going to show a quick
very very adorable little photo super
cute are you sure he's setting us up
look at
that fine ass woman with a [__]
gangster a big rottweiler I like how you
describe that a murder I would have gone
another way but right am I not being
descriptive when women think are ling to
their dogs I don't typically see them as
sex objects that's a fine ass one
doggy he likes to love all right well
this woman just posted super loving
messages to her two dogs online and then
they viciously
attacked profile so way you said that
was she posted messages to her loving
Dogs online yeah she was just talking
about how her dogs are [__] sweet
like how the [__] do you so she posted
online like a regular ass white [__] my
dogs are the best none your [__] do and
then they [__] bit her cuz they're y
they got that retweet and they're like
[__] you talking about us you didn't
hashtag the right [__] she fed okay this
is Australian woman she was probably
kissing the Rott riler and then went
100% it's a
Rottweiler she's got two of them
actually [__] she named she's got
two of them she named them Bronx and
Harlem Bronx and Harlem [__] you know
what them places mean now
girl straight
violence of course she's Australian like
it's all exotic to her yeah yeah this
made up land of Harlem ask for a more
incredible cheeky loyal intelligent and
protective little mate you're my whole
world protective my whole world [__]
it's a dog until they bite her in the
face she after she got the dog one of
her posts was life is complete it's
amazing uh she got the dog as an adult
like the dog was full grown no she was
able to get it and still wish it happy
birthday at one point in one of her
posts um but so it's a rescue so you
don't know the history yeah at age 31
and most people don't know how to train
their dogs and was due to undergo
surgery to save her arm oh no after they
turned on her and bit the [__] out of it
these dogs like recently these aren't
dogs that she's Alpha enough or some
[__] they do the dog training is like
you got to really I have two pugs and I
can't even train them
right they walk all over
me dogs age they all revert back to
their [__] Primal instincts
Jared idiot Jared is a cat lover and a
[__] anti-dog racist
really yes I see it he
hates oh my God
[__] people like just
not big cuddly my dream is for just some
white liberal [__] walking in
California with her [__] dog just
walks by me and her dog Snips I don't
care what it is I'm going to [__]
right outside that dog's head if your
dog me [__] rwe you puss the goal is
for on the show and get LA right you're
turning off half of them right now I
don't care stop talk about the cats and
how much you love them if the dog Snips
at me getting the you have cats no I
don't have any there is a whole thing
though with white girls rescuing pit
bulls and then they get attacked bro or
they're walking the dogs and they're
literally pulling it they're getting
pulled by the you know how many times I
see that it's ter absolutely and it's
this is a stere like
a very specific wi why does have a lot
of love to give
and sometimes the amount of Love they
want to give is it's not really related
to the amount they don't get
back sucks you're like I'm going to love
the [__] out of this rot oil and he's
like I wonder if I could pull her arm
off yeah I'll try it successful worst
case I get blood to
drink he didn't mean it he put the dogs
down wait I'm so confused are these dogs
that she's had for years and they just
ended up tring explain this yeah explain
it or are these like dogs that like the
day before she just picked out at the
pound and she made a post it sounds dud
most
people that seems a little bit more ear
most people that get dogs and they can't
train them they just go back to the
pound and then somebody adopts them and
they have bad behaviors and then you
have to train how much effort it really
takes to train dogs bro I'm trying to
train my little pug to not pee
everywhere and it's like I'm just taking
L's wherever I go you guys man that's
some like that's some [__] capitalist
you know what I'm saying privileged ass
[__] you got to train a dog you do it
first of all a foreign language any
[__] speak a foreign languagein
you know what I'm saying you tell a
[__]
dog you tell a [__] dog some [__] in
Russia they know they can you train my
dog [__] yeah I'll come
over he does ah [__] it's not going to
work but you're like caring on there
like oh my God he's my whole world you
try to treat him like a child and it
doesn't work he's like I ain't no
[__] child I'm a grown dog man yeah
yeah I've been in the streets before I
came to you [__] that's what he's
trying to tell you but he's like I think
he meanss K nope
wrong it was a drug dealer protection
dog enforcer dog and it turns out the
drug dealer was beefing hard with like a
gang of like kons it's just some and one
of them was Australian like the leader
and he's like just make sure you [__]
kill any Australian woman you ever
seen and then he got shot right they put
the dog in the pound and then they FW
across the dude it is history there goes
that arm I'm going to like the the best
dog the most caring sweetest dog she's
going to adopt me the moment we get
home it does say it does say she wished
Happy First Birthday to her baby Bo
Bronx in 2017 okay so she's had these
dogs so it looks like she's had these
dogs really old [__] those dogs don't
live a long time either reverted back to
Primal instincts
again all dogs do it no they don't
you're not my pugs dude never my dogs go
blind and then Yelp and annoy your
neighbors like my [__] neighbors dog
this is a really sad story you guys
don't want toar my my dogs have never
bit me ever no they won't until they're
to die and I've had yeah exactly and
I've had like four German Shepherds I
could stick my hand in their mouth
they've never bit me they bit everybody
they'll bite other people they'll bite
other dogs but they'll never bite me or
my family so loyal damn that's
impressive what you know you're going
get want demena when people have explain
to you that their dog is safe I safe you
see somebody's German Shepherd got those
little [__] Nazi legs you know the
short legs na legs
[__] [__] like that you know
[__] SS tattoo and you're like that
dog's literally [__] Hitler n he's
great with children get the [__] out of
here those those goddamn things for
children too [__] he's looking at me
like I'm either food or I insulted there
automatically when you come in a house
with a [__] guy who has a [__]
mean dog like you Bart you got to
understand like the guy who owns the dog
is the alpha male and if you step to him
that dog is going to [__] kill you so
you got to be like all right like am I
sitting weird do I look at the dog too
much am I being too scared and he knows
I'm weak or am I being too [__] Alpha
and he knows he's got to take a shot at
the title I only deal with dogs that are
[__] useless love machines our
dog Old English Bulldog a beautiful only
one emotion uh too love and laziness
love and laziness
yeah and every now and again like she's
part all the old English Bulldogs are
amalgamation breed so it's part American
Bulldog so this gen in their DNA that
when they hear knock on the door they
[__] bark yeah we never taught her to
do that [__] any of that German show was
like that too knock and she has like a
big girl voice and like the [__]
people come in to work on our TV or some
[__] and I was like you do not have to
take this dog seriously and they never
do
[__] like get the [__] they just pet her
while she's barking and she's still
growling a little bit and they're
petting her she she's shaking her butt
while she's growling but then her Tail's
going really fast L she loves you you're
her new best friend inevitably the
people who have dogs you have to like
explain like rottweiler is like oh yeah
just don't look him in the eyes what the
[__] what if he comes up to me oh it
just just definitely don't look in the
MS [__]
that cherry you ever been bit by a dog
uh no I just don't like him why what's
wrong with you you're going to lose all
your Jerry
followers dog people here ladies ladies
he loves dog he's just a tough shell to
crack so M fren you could fix it
Frenchies are adorable you could fix it
Frenchies are adorable Frenchies are
adorable see he's got a little soft spot
Frenchies look like cats you know that
Latinos in Filipinos like Frenchies they
do [__] love Frenchies he St us all
what about like golden retrievers no I
like golden ret soce too much hair here
yeah it's the hair I don't look I don't
what if they got this haircut though
it's the bark it's the bark it's the
barking and the begging if I'm in the
kitchen and your [__] dog comes up to
me get the [__] adorable
they it's not your time to eat it's not
your time to eat go if they beg that's
the owner's fault my dogs never beg
because that means you've been re bite
me not my food well you just you have't
TR Never B what about like um like
doxins and the stuff cute as [__] too
really what what about the straggler
that comes around that guy is cute too
the little floppy ear that kind of cute
what about basset hounds and stuff when
they how no Anno corgis uh Marvin's
Corgi
it's kind of C yeah see we know his type
now what about pugs just like my tast
women like really small and like ethnic
you know coris are ethnic they're tiny
they're like
[__] they're Welsh yeah that's the
worst you you would how many times
exactly racist [__] well Corgi
just say you like brown women and just
keep it at that J the dog stuff no dogs
dogs that bark dogs that beg can't can't
deal with it so you like cats it doesn't
work for you what kind of cats you like
what do you like about cats I got cats
what cats you have I got Bangals he got
weird crazy cats I want I want an F4 and
like B his cats look wild yeah they're
like they're literally kind of art like
uh do you guys ever see that commercial
for Fancy Feast back in the day where
the cat was like billowing white [__]
Mandarin cat and they give him this like
regular dog food he's like he like
doesn't want it and then he gets the
Fancy Feast oh yeah
I was like I want a cat that knows he's
better bread than
me cat I want him Royal I want like ay
cat that's a cat
personality like a giant manun or
something yo those are badass those are
cool the flat-faced Asian cats with the
big hair everywhere they just look so
[__] like in charge you ever see
those cats with the short legs they're
real cute oh adorable cute but adorable
comes from
Asia
[Music]
a